des observations assez convergentes de
ce point de vue là il ya des rapports
qui ont été rendus par amnesty
international la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme des
travaux plus scientifique ou encore la
demande d' enquête de michelle bachelet
quand elle était haut commissaire aux
droits de l'homme à l'onu au moment du
mouvement des gilet jaune sur autour de
la répression ou du niveau de répression
donc bon il me semble que le on pourrait
parler d'ailleurs de françois sureau
aussi cet avocat qui était plutôt proche
de la droite d'ailleurs un françois
fillon et et macron d'ailleurs qui a
écrit tout un livre pour dire à quel
point les libertés publiques étaient
remises en cause et c'est notamment par
la guerre contre le terrorisme voilà
c'est à dire par l'empilement notamment
de loi anti terroriste par le transfert
de loi qui sont au départ présenté comme
anti casseurs mais à la gestion des des
manifestants et des mobilisations
sociales part on pourrait également
parler de l'armement des dits non létale
mais en réalité qui mutile et qui peut
tuer des policiers qui dans les études
montrent je pense au livre de paul
rocher que cet armement ça a
explosé au cours des dernières années
les policiers sont beaucoup plus doté en
armes qui peuvent qui peuvent le mutiler
notamment les flash ball ou moins lbd et
c'est cette allusion à sébastian roché
plus exactement non je fais en
démocratie main je pensais à pas le
rocher dans un excès rebelles gaz et
mutilé soumettre qui sorti je crois
l'année dernière où il ya deux ans donc
il me semble que le que le constat est
assez état c'est indéniable et
effectivement on peut se dire que il y à
là les éléments on va dire non pas
idéologique mais matériel de possibilité
d'une fascisation de l'état qui n'est
pas du tout accompli à ce stade un loin
de là mais qui pourrait s'opérer dans
une deuxième phase notamment consécutive
à l'arrivée au pouvoir du d'un mouvement
d'extrême droite voilà
[Musique]